this is the guy that I am now obsessed
with and he is a guy and uh I'm gonna
I'm going to I hope he gets famous
because he's not he's got like 2 000
followers
um
and he is will uh William
blunderfield will blunderfield okay you
know will blunderfield is his name
and he is a guy that has a lot of
interesting things to say wait here it
is I'm following him and and here's one
of them right here
what is up Yogi so people say how do you
use your anal plug in a ritualistic
spiritual context simplest way is
conscious connected breathing AKA breath
work with your anal plug in just line
the ground and
breathe so that your perineum your anus
your sex organ your low belly bulges
most people are disconnected from their
Roots so just conscious
passive exhale just lie on the ground
Just Close Your Eyes put on some nice
music or check out uh Robin Clements or
Edward Dangerfield you know
um breath Masters is really good too
Brian Carew has some amazing breath work
basically just lie on the ground plays
amusing breathe with the plug-in and I
actually have a breathwork teacher he'd
lift up our legs he'd stick his perineum
in our his stick his knee in our
perineum to help anchor us as men during
breath work we called him neezus Christ
you can do this by yourself just with a
shock herbs plug use my code wild naked
man where's code
uh we use my code wild naked man dude
unfucking real dude this is not the best
one this is the one that um
one fire sent uh not the best one so one
fire but this one there are some such
good ones dude I mean where's let's see
here
a lot of men have this desire to
Showcase their [ __ ] to each other for
example in the locker room but they have
this fear that if they do that Embrace
that proclivity fully that it might mean
that they're gay or that they're less
than the ideal man but the Spartans did
that yeah Japan period did that certain
times in Ancient India they did that
First Nations tribes they did that
pretty much everywhere before the Matrix
took over did that in terms of an alpha
male Behavior so why are you feeling
Shame about it the only reason why you
feel shame about same-sex erotic bonding
and [ __ ] appreciation rituals is because
the cult that runs this planet is
flushed you into that state hey guy
you're gonna use that much I mean you're
gonna use that many [ __ ]
words that are like legit say penis
instead of [ __ ]
oh man dude there's one
here there's there's one that was just
flipped me out hold on this guy is
unbelievable
so I believe in my body no no it's not
that one wait come on dude just so when
I retain my C ease
same thing happens it's a combination of
sex Kung Fu detoxification
can really ramp up your ability to be
abundant in every sense of the word so
I've got an amazing business opportunity
oh no [ __ ] dude message
addiction proclivity where they think
that if they have a quick little [ __ ]
sneeze and go into PornHub and watch
some some Smite on there that is gonna
like make them feel better in the long
run but the truth is it takes the body
so much energy to create semen like way
more than even blood so if you're
ejaculating when you get stressed you're
actually lowering your ability to handle
the stress and to come back into the
hornesis
let's do it uh and to come back into the
horny
says this guy is unbelievable and you're
welcome dude will blunderfield
hold on a lot of people want to know
about my
tools now while I'm in check this one
you know I
I not many I have
actual honor doing that
um but yeah I guess by tape con it is I
really really believe in Yoni steaming
rituals and
um clitoral and vaginal massage uh
rituals in a circle so basically all the
women perfect kids they uh Brew some
beautiful herb
um steaming teas in a big vat and then
they basically put it underneath their
yoni's AKA their vaginas and they sit in
a circle and they basically steam their
vaginas together it's very very
beautiful uh women would do this well
the shaman dude would lead the alpha
males three erotic bonding rituals so
Yong would be sharpening young and Yin
would be sharpening Yin it's a very
beautiful experience so that's kind of
to my two cents also putting the Jade
egg you can use my I mean what is up
yogis so you gotta have to go in this
this guy is just incredible I am
absolutely loving my new EMS
what was the one where he's talking
about just [ __ ]
playing with his dude's [ __ ] anything
sharpens Young energy hold on
now you guys gotta hear this one sorry
it's a little hack if you you know how a
little bit of indigestion no no no no
I remember if I was probably like 12
years old yeah that's gonna end in tears
um
all right so here it is dude I found it
we had to cut to find it but dude this
is the one man this is the one that is
just the most greatest one so I had an
amazing origami dinner with my bro organ
meat I got naked and we just chilled in
my bed and watched some Obi-Wan Kenobi
and we basically just held each other's
mushrooms
and kind of just like massage the heart
Meridian because in Chinese medicine at
least in classical Chinese medicine
penis is the outermost extension of the
heart especially that heart Murray let's
see if I can show this to you right here
heart Meridian
this is a diagram in terms of penis
reflexology it's a little bit blurry but
you can basically see there's all like
the pineal gland is right before the
urethra the heart is all about the fire
elements yeah small intestine as well it
stores self-hatred cruelty and
impatience so basically we massage each
other's heart meridians to help release
self-hatred while cuddling and watching
Obi-Wan Kenobi
ancestors did they would also suck each
other's nipples and share each other's
beds before Bob
wow through that last one in there they
would also suck each other's nipples and
share each other's beds for before
battle our Celtic ancestors dude anytime
someone anyone brings up Celtic
ancestors they're gone bro they are gone
I cuddled in bed with a guy and robbed
each other's mushroom meridians
robbed each other's mushroom meridians
and watched the new Obi-Wan Kenobi on
Disney plus
hey guy
yay and that's okay but if you're
rubbing the heart meridians if you're
robbing the outermost area of the heart
of the heart according to ancient China
are you gay and that's all right but
also let me go one further if you're
watching Obi-Wan Kenobi you're gay
Star Wars [ __ ] is over
it's stopped
after Jar Jar Binks we were done
okay like Marvel movies okay they made
Moon Knight
bye bye
basically it's just Disney plus is
ruining everything
okay the guy cuddled in bed
and rubbed it's amazing and you know
this guy goes out now by the way I like
this guy so you can follow him but don't
[ __ ] make fun of him I'll do that
go follow him if you're interested in
rubbing Cox with another guy in a
non-gay way only because your Celtic
ancestors did it okay I think it's a
beautiful thing it stores energy and if
you're splurting too much then you get
more stressed out is what he's saying
but anyway I'm gonna take his class
dude he's got so many classes and he's
got codes that you can um
that you can you can pay for I'm gonna
pay for his [ __ ] I should go dude this
guy's incredible a lot of breath work
with his [ __ ] anal plugin
wow but hey you know what anyone happy
good on you man this is cool
I I like this guy but it's incredible
[Music]
saying it's it's not that there's
anything unnatural about same-sex he
read about me but what's happening is
our psyches know that creative or just
being tapping
and that sucks there's nothing more
juicy than being a virile stag-like
Minotaur man who can you know please
women and ravish the ladies
so when that feeling comes back in full
force through superfood nutrition sex
Kung Fu and detox
as well as transmutation and Senior
attention you just human retention and
then the gay Panic goes away right
there's nothing wrong with same-sex
robotic bonding but there's something
very rough about having your sex desire
to procreate be pinched off by chemicals
that they put in the food in the
Pharmaceuticals so oh yeah only uh only
fans.com Bill Butterfield man head
Academy
[Laughter]
what is this world dude head on over to
onlyfans.com dude and watch me [ __ ]
sit on my anal plug and breathe
anyway not gay dude the guys get the
hottest chick I'm not [ __ ] around
here's pictures of him with the hottest
chick it's unbelievable dude
bro what the [ __ ] this world's crazy
dude imagine like somebody from 1940
that like was like already gonna like a
60 year old from 1940 just all of a
sudden being alive today they'd be like
what about anything
they'd be like what
dude holy [ __ ] man
so anyway it's not gay to [ __ ] a guy and
that sucks that people fear it's gay and
I'm not gay anyway uh send uh go over to
my only fans if you're a guy especially
and let's not be gay together
ejaculation ritual you know semen
retention
[ __ ] semen retention
[Music]
congratulations
[Music]